This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及构筑抗压能力。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字TWO点，可在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听。《Look Back at It》播客。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，黄金单身汉明星克雷顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会时，她们决定自己采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。大家好。
I'm Jemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of your 20s. Today, we have a very special episode. It is our 400th episode of the psychology of your 20s, 400th. That is honestly kind of but difficult to fathom at this stage. I don't know, every year when we hit like the next 100th mark of episodes, the next milestone,
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻与转型，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本期播客。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十多岁的心理学。今天，我们有一期非常特别的节目。这是《The Psychology of Your 20s》的第四百集，第四百集。说实话，在这个阶段，这真的有点难以置信。我不知道，每年当我们迎来下一个整百集的里程碑时，
I always get so emotional and like sappy about, I don't know just how far we've come, how amazing the community is. I just feel like this podcast has such an amazing, an amazing, like, origin story in that I started it really not thinking it was going to be anything. It was just a personal project for me to document my 20s. And it's just turned into such, it's just turned into the coolest community. And now having all of these opportunities to obviously be on Netflix, like to go and tour and meet so many of you guys. And like the book that came out last year, like it really is the coolest freaking job ever.
我总是会变得非常情绪化，变得多愁善感，我不知道，只是感叹我们一路走来有多么不容易，这个社群有多么惊艳。我只是觉得这个播客有着如此惊艳、如此了不起的起源故事，我刚开始做它的时候真的没想过它能变成什么样。这只是我记录自己二十多岁生活的个人项目。而它却变成了一个如此……它已经变成了最酷的社群。现在拥有了所有这些机会，比如上Netflix，去巡演，结识你们当中的这么多人。还有去年出版的书，这真的是有史以来最酷、最爽的工作。
Thanks to you guys. And so when this comes around every year, when the birthday rolls around, I always try and do, yeah, I guess a special, a special episode. and this is what we're going to talk about today. Today I want to talk about this list I've been working on for, I think like over the past month or so, the list of 15 things I think everybody should do in their 20s. The 15 things that may not be the most widely applauded achievements or milestones that society wants you to celebrate,
感谢你们大家。所以每当这个时候到来，每当生日来临时，我总是会尝试去做一期，是的，我想是一期特别的节目，这就是我们今天要聊的内容。今天我想聊聊我一直在准备的一份清单，我想大概有一个多月了吧，这是我认为每个人在二十多岁时都应该做的15件事的清单。这15件事可能不是社会希望你庆祝的那些最受赞誉的成就或里程碑，
but which I think will help us make the most of this decade and enter our 30s and enter the rest of our lives, feeling like we really did and saw and directed our lives in like the best possible way. I obviously think about my 20s, our 20s, a lot as a concept and as like an important life chapter, but I especially think about how to make the most of them. This decade feels kind of like the last time when we're truly able to experiment, take risks, make mistakes, get away with things. obviously like life continues after our 20s and we are able to reinvent ourselves until the day we
但我认为它们能帮助我们充分利用这个十年，带着一种真正经历过、见证过并以最佳方式掌控自己人生的感觉，迈入三十岁以及我们人生的余下阶段。我显然经常把二十多岁、我们的二十多岁作为一个概念和一个重要的人生章节来思考，但我尤其在思考如何充分利用它们。这个十年感觉就像是我们真正能够尝试、冒险、犯错、侥幸过关的最后一次机会。很显然，生命在我们的二十多岁之后仍在继续，直到我们死亡的那一天，我们都能够重塑自我，直到我们死亡的那一天，我们都能够去冒险。
die and able to take risks until the day we die. But I do think there are some experiences that are really crucial just to have during this decade, if not for the first time, the only time. And they leave a very, very sizable impact on us. I also think again, like that list or milestone checklist that society tends to feed us where we have to graduate, find our dream job, find our life partner get married, buy a house, maybe have a baby, live happily ever after is also very outdated. And despite its best intentions, I think those milestones miss the mark. And they actually miss a lot of experiences that are just as important. So today for our 400th episode, I have rounded up the experiences, lessons, bucket list items that I think are most essential to do in our 20s
但我确实认为，有些经历在这个十年里经历是绝对至关重要的，即使不是第一次，也是唯一的一次。它们对我们产生了非常非常深远的影响。我也再次认为，社会往往灌输给我们的那种清单或里程碑核对表——即我们必须毕业、找到梦想的工作、找到人生的伴侣、结婚、买房、也许生个孩子、从此过上幸福的生活——也已经非常过时了。尽管它有着最好的初衷，但我认为那些里程碑并未击中要害。它们实际上漏掉了许多同样重要的经历。所以今天为了我们的第四百集，我整理了那些我认为在二十多岁时最不可或缺的经历、教训和心愿单事项，
or to have some kind of contact with in our 20s, it's not going to be the traditional checklist that you think of. It's definitely going to be a bit more unconventional. So if you are finding that, you know, your 20s aren't going according to plan, I think if you're able to check some of these things off this list, you are doing an incredible job. And I think it will help us and it has helped me making this list know where to direct my attention to outside of love,
或者是在二十多岁时需要与之有所接触的事物，它不会是你想象中的那种传统核对表。它绝对会有些非同寻常。所以如果你发现，你知道，你的二十多岁没有按计划进行，我想如果你能勾选这份清单上的某些事情，你已经做得非常棒了。而且我认为这会帮助我们——它也曾帮过我——在制作这份清单时知道该把注意力引导到哪里去，除了爱情、
outside of my career, outside of financial goals, which is very, very important for our development in this decade. So without further ado, let's get into the 15 best things you need to do in your 20s. Okay, so let's start with some of my more basic run-of-the-mill items that I put on this list before we get into some of the more controversial ones. The first big one is just to live away from home. And I don't mean home in terms of like your childhood home or move out of your parents' house. That's obviously an amazing start. And this will require you to do that. I do mean more like live away from the city, the region, the town that feels like your place.
除了我的职业、除了财务目标之外，这些对于我们在这个十年的发展非常非常重要。废话不多说，让我们进入在二十多岁时你需要做的15件最好的事情。好了，让我们从这份清单上一些更基础、更常规的项目开始，然后再进入那些更具争议性的项目。第一件大事就是离家独立生活。我指的家不是指你童年时的家或者搬出父母的家。那显然是一个了不起的开始，而这需要你做到这一点。我更想说的是，离开那个让你觉得属于你的城市、地区或小镇。
Even if that place is New York City or Beijing or London or like one of the biggest cities in the world, there are still opportunities a place like that or any other place cannot offer you. if it is the only place you remain. And not just career opportunities, but development opportunities, cultural opportunities, friendship opportunities. I think this will be one of the more privileged items on this list. And some people, as we know, don't have the means, don't have the desire to do this.
即使那个地方是纽约、北京、伦敦或世界上的某个超级大都市，如果那里是你停留的唯一地方，依然有一些是那样的地方或其他任何地方无法提供给你的机会。不仅仅是职业机会，还有发展机会、文化机会、友谊机会。我认为这将是这份清单上比较有特权的项目之一。正如我们所知，有些人没有经济条件，也没有意愿这样做。
But if there is even a sliver of you that is unhappy where you are, And if there is even a small part of you that is thinking about whether there is more and whether you should do this, you absolutely should. There is totally more out there for you. And the fact that you are thinking about it shows that a part of you is obviously calling for that and is obviously slightly dissatisfied. The reason this is my number one on the list is because it is probably also one of the biggest patent disruptors we can have in our 20s that we get to opt into voluntarily. all the other pattern disruptors or big life changes are sometimes not as kind to us. Sometimes they're things we don't choose. A pattern disruptor like this, like moving out of your hometown, moving overseas,
但如果你内心哪怕有一丝一毫对现状感到不快乐，如果你内心哪怕有一小部分在思考外面是否还有更多可能，以及你是否应该这样做，你绝对应该去。外面完全有更多广阔的天地在等着你。而你脑子里有这种想法，说明你内心的某一部分显然在呼唤这种改变，显然也带有一点不满足。之所以这是我清单上的第一项，是因为这很可能是我们在二十多岁时能够主动选择的、对生活模式最大的颠覆之一。所有其他的模式颠覆或重大生活改变有时对我们并不那么友善。有时它们是我们无法选择的事情。像这样打破常规的颠覆，比如搬离你的家乡、移居海外，
it's something that just automatically is able to pull us away from our habits, pull us away from our regular way of being, our routine, pull us out of our boredom. And it's like this instant shift onto a new timeline. It's this instant shift into a new life. It breaks the habit of being yourself, the habit of being your old self. And it's truly incredible because of how much it is going to ask from you and how much it is going to stretch you and how much the world opens up. That is the beauty of leaving, of saying goodbye.
这是一件能够自动将我们从习惯中拉出来的事情，把我们从常规的生存方式、日常生活中拉出来，把我们从无聊中拉出来。这就像是瞬间切换到了一条新的时间线。这就像是瞬间切换到了崭新的人生。它打破了做自己的习惯，打破了做那个老旧自己的习惯。这真的是不可思议的，因为它将对你提出多少要求，它将如何拓展你，以及世界将向你敞开多少。这就是离开的魅力，也是说再见的魅力。
I just think you owe it to yourself if you're thinking about moving overseas, thinking about living by yourself, thinking about moving out of your hometown. Like, you truly do owe it to yourself to see what's out there. you truly do owe it to yourself to realize that, like, I don't know, it's just, you've been gifted, this huge, wonderful world, and hopefully you do get to see more of it than just the corner you were born into, even if it's not permanent, even if you just have, like, a decade-defining adventure of traveling for three months, of working in a foreign country, of just, like, volunteering in the middle of nowhere, it will just transform you as a person. And I do just think,
我只是觉得，如果你在考虑移居海外，在考虑独自生活，在考虑搬离家乡，你真的亏欠自己去看看外面的世界。你真的亏欠自己去意识到，比如，我不知道，这只是，你被赋予了这个巨大而美好的世界，希望你确实能看到更多，而不仅仅是你出生的那个角落，即使这不是永久的，即使你只是拥有了一次定义十年的冒险——旅行三个月，在国外工作，或者只是在穷乡僻壤做志愿者，它都会彻底改变你作为个人的成长。我确实认为，
it is essential to your development to put yourself in the hot water of having to adjust to a whole new way of being and a whole new life and just of like kind of being on your own. Okay, the second thing on the list, understand how money works and how it actually works like below the surface of basic concepts. One of my biggest regrets of my early 20s was that I just kind of assumed that the basics I've been taught about money were correct and were all there was to know. And I think a lot of us probably had a similar education where you were taught about the importance of a savings account, a budget, an emergency fund. And that was probably like where the ball stopped if it even got there. Basically, like, I remember being taught
让自己陷入必须适应全新生活方式、全新人生以及某种程度上独处的水深火热之中，对你的成长至关重要。好了，清单上的第二件大事：理解金钱是如何运作的，以及它在基础概念的表象之下是如何真正运作的。我二十出头时最大的遗憾之一，就是我理所当然地认为我被灌输的关于金钱的基础知识是正确的，而且这就是金钱的全部。我想我们很多人大概都接受过类似的教育，你被教导了储蓄账户、预算、应急基金的重要性。而这大概就是知识的终点，如果它甚至能达到这个程度的话。基本上，我记得我曾被教导
your money is either spent or saved. When you start to realize the possibility that money actually holds and how so many financial concepts and systems are being gate kept from you and keeping you dependent on a fixed income and the nine to five. Like, you will be totally honestly shocked and just like, yeah, gobsmacked. I remember having this realization, especially in university, because that was like the first time that I'd met really rich people, like really rich people for the first time who talked about assets and investment properties and stocks, bonds, ETFs, high yield savings account, like all this linger that had kind of like swirled around me but I never really thought to learn about. And now having really like made sure I know
你的钱要么花掉了，要么存起来了。当你开始意识到金钱实际拥有的潜力，以及有多少金融概念和系统被故意对你设限，从而让你依赖固定收入和朝九晚五的生活时，你绝对会感到震惊，而且……嗯，简直是目瞪口呆。我记得我曾有过这种顿悟，尤其是在大学里，因为那是第一次我遇到真正富有的人，生平第一次见到那些谈论资产、投资性房产、股票、债券、ETF、高收益储蓄账户的真正有钱人，所有这些曾经在我耳边盘旋但我从未真正想过去了解的行话。现在我真的确保自己懂得了，
and made sure I educated myself, that is why this tip always makes any list I make about things to do in your 20s or regrets about my 20s. The best thing you can do for your future self right now is to spend eight hours over the next week, over the next month, learning how money actually works, learning how investing works, learning how low the barrier for entry really is when it comes to like the stock market or when it comes to bonds or when it comes to investing, even just like open up a trading account. You don't have to put any money in it. Open off like a high yield savings account. Just take the first step to being a part of the ecosystem or being a part of the population who understands money beyond just the buy and save kind of mindset.
并确保自己接受了教育，这就是为什么这个建议总能进入我列出的“二十多岁要做的事”或“二十多岁的遗憾”的任何清单中。为了未来的自己，你现在能做的最好的事情，就是在接下来的一个星期、接下来的一个月里花上八个小时，去了解金钱到底是如何运作的，了解投资是如何运作的，了解当涉及到股市、债券或投资时，准入门槛其实有多么低，甚至只是开一个交易账户。你不需要往里面放钱。开一个像高收益储蓄账户之类的东西。迈出成为生态系统或理解金钱的人群的一部分的第一步，而不仅仅停留在买入和储蓄的心态上。
And there's just so many amazing resources. Friends that invest is one of my like favorite online resources to learn. Even just like going to your bank's webpage and looking up like how to invest, you'll know more than so many people and it will definitely show. Okay. Next on the list, learn how to send things back. more generally, I really mean like learn how to stick up for yourself. Now, when I say learn how to send things back, obviously I mean like learn how to send things
而且有那么多绝佳的资源。“Friends that invest”是我最喜欢的在线学习资源之一。甚至只是访问你银行的网页，搜索诸如“如何投资”之类的内容，你就会比许多人懂得更多，而且这绝对会显现出效果。好了。清单上的下一项：学会退货。更广泛地说，我实际上是指：学会为自己挺身而出。现在，当我说的学会退货时，很显然我的意思是：学会把餐厅里的东西退回去。
back at the restaurant. Like if they get your order wrong, learn how to be like, that's not what I wanted in a kind way, learn how to be like, that's not what I asked for, learn how to be like, that's not the behavior or, you know, the thing that I deserve, the attitude that I deserve. more generally I really mean at some stage in your 20s, you need to learn that being nice, being kind, being polite and being respectful are not all the same thing. There is a lot of nuance to our good behavior and there's a lot of people who benefit from us believing that being a kind person means we have to be passive, overly nice, overly self-effacing.
比如如果他们弄错了你的订单，学会以一种友善的方式说“这不是我想要的”，学会说“这不是我要求的”，学会说“这不是我应得的行为，或者是……我应得的那个东西，我应得的态度”。更广泛地说，我真正想说的是，在你二十多岁的某个阶段，你需要明白：表现得好、表现得善良、表现得礼貌和表现得尊重并不完全是一回事。我们的良好行为中包含着许多细微的差别，有很多人从我们坚信“做一个善良的人就意味着我们必须被动、过分友善、过分自我贬低”中受益。
it is really critical that during this decade, you start to unlearn that. For the first half of my 20s, I think I just kind of let people walk all over me. I would never send anything back at a restaurant. I would never complain about anything. I would never stand up for myself. And I just lost out on so much. And I just wasted so much money and time. and it only like changed very recently actually when I was in Australia and I was living at this house
在这个十年里，你开始戒掉这种观念是至关重要的。在我二十多岁的前半段，我想我只是任由别人践踏我。我从来不在餐厅里退回任何东西。我从来不抱怨任何事情。我从来不为自己挺身而出。我错失了太多。我白白浪费了那么多的金钱和时间。而这一切直到最近才真正改变，当时我在澳大利亚，住在纽顿的那个房子里，
in Newtown and it's like kind of a funny story but there was just this one day where I had this neighbor who didn't like me very much and who I didn't get along with very well who was kind of this older woman and one day it was like 3 p.m and we were like playing I don't know Charlie XX it was a beautiful sunny day and she like came out and she she's like let loose at me and she was yelling at me she was like obviously had been very frustrated by me and she was like how are you playing music we were like well it's 3 p.m anyways long story short it was just this moment where I was like being really really nice being very apologetic and then I kind of just was like I don't really have to take this anymore like I'm not a
这是一个挺搞笑的故事，但就是有那么一天，大概下午三点钟，我有一个邻居，她不太喜欢我，我和她也合不来，她是一个有点年纪的妇女。然后有一天，大约下午三点，我们当时在放，我不知道是查理XCX的歌，那是一个美丽晴朗的日子，她突然冲了出来，她对我大发雷霆，她冲着我大喊大叫，她显然对我很不满，她喊道：“你怎么在放大声音乐？”我们当时就回道：“呃，这会儿才下午三点啊……”总之长话短说，那正是一个这样的时刻：我一开始表现得非常非常友好，一直在道歉，然后我突然就想：“我其实没必要忍受这个……我不是小孩子了，我又不会惹麻烦，我不是个小孩……我完全可以为自己挺身而出。”这太有趣了，
little kid like I can't get in trouble I'm not a child like I can just stick up for myself and it was so interesting, like, seeing how her approach to me just, like, shifted in that moment and seeing how she, I genuinely, this is going to sound so weird, but I felt like I became, like, an adult in that moment, and I could see her in her eyes how she was viewing me as a child in the beginning, and then the moment that I, like, switched and stood up for myself, she started treating me as an adult. And I just think it's such an essential skill to just be like, actually, I don't deserve this, actually, I don't want this, actually, I didn't order this and I'm going to say something because my time and my money and my wants and my needs and
看到她在那一刻对我的态度是如何转变的，看到她……我真心觉得——这听起来可能很奇怪——我觉得自己在那一刻真正成长为一个成年人了。我能从她的眼睛里看到，一开始她把我当成一个孩子来看待，而当我扭转态度、为自己挺身而出的那一刻，她开始把我当成一个成年人来对待。我只是觉得这绝对是一项必不可少的技能，去说出：“事实上，我不配遭受这些，实际上，我并不想要这个，实际上，我没有点这个，我要说出来，因为我的时间、我的金钱、我的愿望、我的需求以及
desires are just as important as anybody else. The four thing you should absolutely do in your 20s. Quit something you really depended on. Whether that is nicotine, whether that is alcohol, whether that is a person, a bad habit, whatever it is, this will be one of the hardest things I think you do, it will also probably save your life. In a very obvious way for some things, in a very physical way, like with alcohol, like with tobacco, but also in a mental and emotional and psychological way as well. Quitting something you're dependent on will prove to you that you are capable of being in control of your own behavior. Otherwise, you will always be limited by the that controls you. When you decide, when you make a conscious decision of like, actually, I don't
渴望和任何其他人一样重要。”第四件你绝对应该在二十多岁时做的事。戒掉你非常依赖的东西。无论是尼古丁、酒精、某个人、一个坏习惯，还是其他什么，我认为这将是你做过的最艰难的事情之一，但它也可能会救了你的命。在某些事情上它以一种非常明显、非常客观的方式救你的命，比如戒酒、戒烟，但它同时也在心理、情感和精神层面上拯救你。戒掉你依赖的东西会向你证明，你有能力掌控自己的行为。否则，你将永远受制于那个控制你的东西。当你下定决心，当你做出一个有意识的决定：“实际上，我对这个东西毫无控制力，而我想夺回控制权”，你就在重建内在调节的能力，而不再外在地依赖某样东西。你重建了你的自主感。你重建了掌控自我的能力。
have any control over this and I want to take back my control, you rebuild your ability to internally regulate without being externally reliant on something. You rebuild your sense of agency. You rebuild your ability to be in control. Essentially, in psychology, we call it like self-efficacy, the ability to master your reality and master your experiences and to essentially say, I'm going to put my mind to something and I'm going to do it and I can trust myself to do it. You really kind of realize that when you quit something, whatever it is, this bad addictive thing, you are all you need. Like you are truly all you need.
本质上，在心理学中，我们称之为“自我效能感”，即掌控你的现实和经历的能力，并且本质上能够说：“我要专心致志地做一件事，我就能把它做好，而且我相信自己能做到。”当你戒掉某样东西时，无论它是什么，这个具有成瘾性的坏东西，你真的会意识到，你拥有自己需要的一切。就像你真正需要的一切只有你自己。你其实并不需要这个东西来生存。从经历过这一点并征服了它之后，你在自己身上获得的自信和笃定——坚信自己内心强大、拥有韧性、有能力做困难的事情——是……这听起来可能有点老套……比任何药物、任何物质都要强大。从“我实际上能掌控自己与这东西的关系，如果它不能让我快乐，我们就不必再保持这种关系”中获得的这种对自己的信任，是极其强大的，也是你走向成熟、不断长大、认真对待自己和人生的一个巨大标志。第五件，又一件老套的事。
You actually don't need this thing to survive. And from that and having done that and conquered that, the confidence and self-assurance that you have in yourself, that you are mentally strong, that you are resilient, that you are capable of doing hard things, is, and this is going to sound so cliche, like more powerful than any drug, more powerful than any substance, that's self-trust that you gain from being like, I am actually in control of my relationship with this thing. And if it is not making me happy, we don't have to have a relationship anymore, is supremely powerful and like such a big sign that you are maturing and you are growing up and you are taking yourself and your life seriously. Number five, another cliche one.
对不起，但是在你的二十多岁，你需要爱上一项完全为了自己而做的爱好或练习。现在，我要握住你的手，非常严肃地问你这个问题。你有爱好吗？你有一个经常练习、并且真心觉得它是你身份核心部分的爱好吗？你有一个与赚钱无关、与别人如何看你无关、与上网刷屏或消费无关的爱好吗？你有一个纯粹以自我为中心的宣泄口吗？在我们二十多岁的时候，这太容易做到了。在这个当前的媒体大环境下，无论在什么年纪，都很容易变成一个只知道不断消费、消费再消费的人。我总是说的一句话是：人如其食，你同时也是你为自己创造的数字和外部环境。
I'm sorry, but in your 20s, you need to fall in love with a hobby or a practice that you do just for yourself. I'm going to hold your hand and ask you this very seriously right now. Do you have a hobby? Do you have a hobby that you regularly practice, that you genuinely find is a core part of who you are? do you have a hobby that has nothing to do with making money, nothing to do with how other people see you, nothing to do with being online, scrolling or consuming? Do you have a purely self-centered outlet? It's so easy in our 20s. And at any age in this like current media landscape to just be somebody who consumes and consumes and consumes. And the thing I always say is like, you are what you eat, you are also the digital and external environment that you create for yourself.
因此，如果你没有什么超越自身、感觉像是你可以浇灌的花园的东西，如果你没有什么超越自身、感觉像是你可以倾注生命和爱意的东西，并且即使它变糟了或结果不好也完全无所谓——它只是为你而存在的。我确实认为，当你步入三十岁以及人生的余下阶段时，你将会面临某种危机时刻。因为你身份中这个重大的标志和重要部分依然极其不稳定。你身份中独立于任何外部事物的那个部分将会相当摇摇欲坠。所以这是一个警钟，它也是给我自己的警钟。
And so if you don't have anything beyond you that feels like a garden that you can water, and if you don't have anything beyond you that feels like something that you can pour life and love into, and if it goes bad or if it is bad, it really doesn't matter. It's just for you. I do think that you will enter your 30s and enter the rest of your life at a bit of a crisis point. because this big hallmark and important part of your identity remains deeply unstable. The part of your identity that is separate from anything external will remain quite shaky. So this is the wake up call and it's a wake up call for me as well.
真正去找到一件你喜欢做的事，然后把它做好，或者享受独立做好它的乐趣，不管别人是否认为它有价值。基本上就是：培养一个爱好。好了，我们要稍微休息一下，不过接下来，但我们稍事休息后，
Really find something that you like doing and get good at it or get good at enjoying it independently whether other people see worth in it or not. Get a hobby, basically. Okay, we're going to take a short break, but then we're going to take a short break, But then we will be right back with more of our list items. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
马上就会回来继续我们的清单项目。《2%》。这就是有电梯可用时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代社会中，如何培养心理韧性、保持体能以及构筑抗压能力。我将与作家、研究人员、其他健康与健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的超级伪科学。我们真的曾深信种子油生来就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex super. pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们在世界上感到惊恐的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》。即T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，可在iHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？
That's T-W-O-P-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。需要澄清的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为国会。
Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
可卡因。我随时准备在白天谈论可卡因，只是为了让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把那句话说完。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
我说的有，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了那个东西。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？
I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth?
你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
打开你免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前黄金单身汉明星克雷顿·埃克德发现自己身处亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中惊人的不一致之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破了案。
Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的杀毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在《The Girlfriends》的这个新季节里，噢天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯骗子约会。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么会发生在我身上呢？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何平台收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。我想我们已经讲到第六点了。这是我认为这份清单中最重要、最实用的内容之一，那就是：找到一种能够引起你共鸣的方式来记录你的生活，无论那是一个像这样的播客、一个私密的Instagram、一本年度手账、手帐拼贴、垃圾手账（junk journaling）还是相册。这极其重要。当我二十出头的时候，我经常做一个叫做“每天一秒钟”的事情。我不知道你们是否听说过这个。这是一个在2017、2018年左右非常火爆、红极一时的App，要求你每天录制一秒钟的视频，然后在年底的时候，你和你的朋友们会把它们上传到YouTube上。也许这只是一段独特的经历。而之所以记录生活对我们的心理学和心理健康如此至关重要，是因为它在叙事心理学中发挥的作用。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we're up to number six. This is one of the most important ones and practical ones that I think I have on this list, which is find a way to document your life that resonates with you, whether that is a podcast like this one, a private Instagram, a yearly scrapbook, journaling, junk journaling, photo albums. This is so deeply important. When I was in my early 20s, I used to do this thing called one second every day. I don't know if you guys have heard about this. It's this app that had this
叙事心理学是这个播客中的一个流行语，我认为这是我们最常使用的短语之一，也是最相关的概念之一。但本质上，叙事心理学所表达的是：如果你的人生核心没有贯穿一个故事，如果你没有对自己讲述关于自己人生的故事，如果你的经历没有被连结起来，如果你无法记住它们，
major, huge moment, maybe in like 2017, 2018, where you would record one second every day and then at the end of the year, like, all of you and your friends would like upload them to YouTube. Maybe this is just a unique experience. And the reason why, and the reason why documenting life is so essential for our psychology and for our mental health is because of the role it plays in narrative psychology. I narrative psychology is such a buzzword on this podcast I think it's one of our most used phrases and most related to concepts but essentially what narrative psychology says is that if you don't have a story that is running through the center of your life you don't have a story that you are telling yourself about your life if your experiences are not connected if you cannot remember them
你将很难认清自己，也将很难从生活中获得你需要的教训，从生活中获得你需要的快乐，因为生活的一部分乐趣其实是对旅程的感激。生活的一部分乐趣在于事后的回味。在于回首自己21岁、23岁和24岁时的模样，看着照片，通过手账或垃圾手账看到那些生活的残余痕迹，然后感叹自己一路走来有多么不容易。尤其是在我们的二十多岁，这个十年就像是一个充满经历的肥沃油田。它就像是学习、探索和塑造自我身份的肥沃土壤。我认为，如果你想继续从这些经历中学习，或者继续从你正在学习的教训中获益，最简单的方法之一就是拥有某种关于这一时期的物理提醒，让你能够带着它进入你人生的下一个章节。所以如果你还没开始，现在就开始记录你的二十多岁吧。
you will really struggle to know who you are and you will really struggle to get the lessons you need out of life, get the joy you need out of life, because part of the joy of life is really being appreciative of the journey. And part of the joy of life is hindsight. Is the hindsight of getting to look back at who you were at 21 and 23 and 24, see images, see like remnants of that life through scrapbooks or through like junk journaling and just kind of see how far you've come. And especially in our 20s, like this decade is like this rich oil field of experiences. And it's just like such fertile soil for learning and discovering and for identity. And I think that if you want to continue to learn from those experiences or continue to have
第七点，全力以赴地坠入爱河，即使心碎的可能性绝对让人感到恐惧。网上有很多关于约会的言论，我认为这坦白说会让爱情变得非常非常混乱。比如那些病毒式传播的文章：“有男朋友很尴尬吗？”“为什么你应该同时和三个人约会？”“谁来买单？”
the lessons that you are learning, one of the easiest ways to do that is to have some kind of physical reminder of who you were during this time for you to kind of like bring forward with you into the next chapters of your life. So if you haven't started yet, start documenting your 20s now. Number seven, throw yourself deeply into love, even if the possibility of heartbreak is absolutely terrifying. There's all these dating narratives online that I think can honestly make love very, very confusing. You know, articles that go viral about like, it's having a boyfriend embarrassing. Why should you be dating three people at once? Who pays the bill?
“双发信息（double texting）说明了什么？”“几个月前可以官宣（soft launch）？”“几个月前可以大方公开（hard launch）？”所有这些试图围绕爱情制定规则以使其更安全的尝试。这只能意味着我认为我们把它想得太多了。有时你只需要用老式的方法去做。有时候，为了你的个人发展和自我提升，你能做的最好的事情，就是对某个人爱得无可救药、愚蠢至极，哪怕你会受到伤害。
What does double texting say about me? How many months before I soft launch? how many months before I hard launch, like all these attempts to create rules around love to make it safer. And it just means that I think we overthink it too much. Sometimes you just got to do it the old-fashioned way. Sometimes the best thing you can do for your personal development and for your self-improvement is to just be like stupidly in love with somebody and just to fall ridiculously hard, even if you get hurt.
你知道吗？我仿佛已经听到另一端有很多唱反调的人在说：“那是糟糕的建议，那就是人们受伤的方式。”我不知道有什么不对。如果这个人不是那种虐待狂混蛋，受点小伤又有什么不对呢？心碎一点又有什么不对呢？去真切地感受爱情带来的深刻教训和震撼，老实说，如果没有心碎，我就什么都不是。
And you know what? I can already hear a lot of nays say. on the other end of this being like, that is terrible advice, that's how people get hurt. I don't know what's wrong. If this person isn't like an abusive asshole, like, what's wrong with getting a little bit hurt? What's wrong with getting your heart a little bit broken? And just really feeling like the profound lessons and shocks of love, genuinely, I would not be, I would have nothing without heartbreak.
环顾我的生活、我在伦敦的公寓、我的工作、我的狗、我的朋友们，还有我不知道的书……所有这些，我想说的是：如果那几段感情——我想到了几段特定的关系——没有以那样的方式结束，如果我完全坦白地说，其中有一段感情我进入时就确信自己会受伤。我想我内心的某个部分对此释怀了，因为我想：“但接下来的事情将会酷炫无比。”谈谈我们二十多岁时的肥沃土壤吧。分手绝对是你将遇到的最肥沃的情感土壤。它们会彻底改变你的人生。它们简直就像是自我发展的类固醇。所以，即使这段关系没有成功，
I look around at like my life and my apartment in London and my job and my dog and my friends and I don't know my book like just all these things and I'm like I would have none of this if those like and I'm thinking of like a couple specific relationships but like yeah if a couple specific relationships hadn't worked out and if I'm being completely honest one of those relationships for sure I entered knowing I was going to get hurt. And I think a part of me made peace with that because I was like, but what comes after is going to be freaking amazing. Like talk about fertile soil in our 20s. Like breakups are the most fertile emotional soil that you will come across. They will transform your life. They are genuinely like steroids for self-development. So even if the relationship doesn't work out,
如果你有机会把一切都押在爱情上，并且表现得像“我完全准备好在这里被彻底粉碎了”，我认为你绝对应该去这样做。如果你不同意我的观点，那也没关系。欢迎随时就这一点给我发一些反馈。第八点，辞掉你的第一份工作，即使那是你的梦想工作。又是一个充满争议的观点。我辞掉了我的梦想工作。我辞掉了我的梦想工作，因为我内心深处清楚地知道，过于舒适会让我离停滞不前越来越近。
If you have the opportunity to just like bet it all on love and to just be like, I'm so down to just get obliterated here, I think you should absolutely do it. And if you don't agree with me, that's also okay. Feel free to send me some feedback on that one. Number eight, quit the first job you have, even if it is your dream job. Another controversial one. I quit my dream job. I quit my dream job because a major part of me knew that like, being too comfortable gets me pretty close to being stagnant.
如果你有机会把一切都押在爱情上，并且下定决心说，“我完全愿意在这里粉身碎骨”，我认为你绝对应该这么做。如果你不同意我的看法也没关系。随时欢迎就这一点向我发送反馈。第八条，辞掉你的第一份工作，哪怕那是你的梦想工作。又是一个有争议的观点。我辞掉了我的梦想工作。我辞掉梦想工作是因为我内心深处很清楚，过分安逸会让我离停滞不前不远了。
I just think, again, you have to let yourself see what else is out there and see what else could come at you. You have to increase like your target space for luck to hit you. And if you just stay in the same space, if you just stay in the same job, even if it is really an amazing job and it is paying you really well and you worked really hard for it, I think you get left with a lot of what-ifs. And the thing is, is that this is the time in your life when you are and can be the most resilient. So exiting or leaving the dream job means that during this time means that you're going to have as many
我只是觉得，话说回来，你必须让自己去看看外面还有什么，看看还有什么可能会找上门来。你必须扩大你的目标空间，好让运气能砸中你。如果你一直呆在同一个空间里，如果你一直做着同样的工作，哪怕它真的是一份极其棒的工作，薪水也很高，而且你为此付出了巨大的努力，我想你心里最后还是会留下很多“如果当初”。关键在于，这是你人生中精力最充沛、也最能吃苦的阶段。所以，在这个阶段选择放弃或离开梦想中的工作，意味着你将拥有尽可能多
and the most years you'll probably ever have to come back to it if it does end up being the thing that you love. But it's also the time that you're going to have the most years to just explore and to figure things out. this is deeply anecdotal, right? I don't know if people who do this are happier. I can't like give you the promise, but anecdotally, the people I hear from and the people I see who are kind of at like the precipice of turning 40 or turning 30 who feel the most unsure about their careers are actually those who stayed or who seemingly have the most stable careers because they've been in the same job for a very long time. And it's very hard to leave those environments, but I think you, again, just owe it to yourself to just be like,
而且如果你最后发现这确实是你热爱的事业，你很可能还会拥有这辈子最多的时间去重新回到它身边。但这也是你拥有最多时间去单纯地探索、去搞清楚事情的阶段。这完全是个人的切身体会，对吧？我不知道这样做的人是不是会更快乐。我没法向你打包票，但据我所知，我听到过以及看到的那些即将迎来40岁或30岁、对自己的职业生涯感到最迷茫的人，实际上反而是那些留下来的人，或者看似拥有最稳定职业生涯的人，因为他们在同一份工作上呆了很长很长时间。要离开那样的环境非常难，但我认为你同样需要对自己好一点，去想想：
what else could hit me? What other things could happen to me if I just like let my life and my weeks and my months be open to them? Okay, number nine, I need you to make a loose and aspirational plan for your life. This is what I call the Great Life Plan, very easily marketable name. This is not a five-year plan. I kind of hate those. It is not a step-by-step master plan for your entire life. It is just a delusionally optimistic vision for what you want your life to be in 20 years, 50 years, 15 years would, if everything went according to plan. The goal of this is not for it to go according to plan. The goal of it is actually for it not to all come true. Most of the time it won't. A lot of luck and fate and context comes into play. The goal of this great life plan is just to
还有什么可能会降临在我身上？如果我只是让我的生活、我的每一周和每一个月都对各种可能性保持开放，还会发生些什么别的事情呢？好了，第九点，我需要你为自己的人生做一个宽泛且有抱负的规划。这就是我所说的“伟大人生计划”，一个非常容易推广的名字。这不是五年计划。我有点讨厌那种计划。它也不是针对你整个人生的分步总体规划。它只是对你希望自己在20年、50年、15年后生活成什么样的一种极度乐观的构想——如果一切都按计划进行的话。这个目标的意义并不是让一切按计划进行。它的真正意义其实在于它并不需要全部实现。大多数时候它都不会实现。会有许多运气、命运和情境因素在起作用。这个伟大人生计划的目标只是
provide an aspirational structure or like a vision that you can work towards that inspires you. There are a few reasons why I think we all need to like at some stage sit down and articulate this and why I think it's important. I think it's important because it keeps you focused on what is meaningful to you and what is not meaningful and therefore unnecessary. So much of our 20s is sometimes focused on what seems outwardly impressive, what others are doing that we feel like we have to. The detours, the milestones, we feel like we need to check off. But if that doesn't actually align with your plan, don't do it. And if you don't know what your plan is, you will end up doing a lot of things you actually never wanted to do in the first place.
提供一个宏大的结构或愿景，让你能够为之奋斗并受到启发。为什么我认为我们所有人都需要在某个阶段坐下来明确这一点，以及为什么我认为它很重要，原因有几个。我认为它很重要，因为它能让你专注于对你真正有意义的事情，而忽略那些没有意义、因而不必要的事情。我们20多岁的时候，有太多时间往往专注于那些表面上看起来令人印象深刻的事情，专注于别人在做而我们觉得不得不去做的事情。那些弯路、那些人生里程碑，我们觉得我们必须去打勾完成。但如果这实际上并不符合你的计划，那就别去做。如果你不知道你的计划是什么，你最后就会做很多你从一开始就根本不想做的事情。
If your long-term vision of happiness isn't to live overseas, don't go and live overseas if you know that's not what you need to be happy. If your long-term vision is to have your own business, don't feel so pressured by everyone's promotions on LinkedIn and believe that's what you need to be doing. It's not your dream. It's not your plan. You have to be able to articulate what your vision is. As long as that is what you are working towards. It really helps you keep your blinders up to everybody else and everything else that's going on around you. It stops us from being as well, I think, passive by only thinking a few feet ahead of ourselves as well. Like it stops us from being stuck in the moment of needing everything to be perfect right now.
如果你对长期幸福的愿景并不是去海外生活，那就不要去海外生活，如果你明知那并不是你获得幸福所必需的。如果你长期的愿景是拥有自己的企业，那就不要被领英上所有人的升职搞得压力重重，并相信那就是你需要去做的事情。那不是你的梦想，那不是你的计划。你必须能够清晰地表达出你的愿景是什么。只要那是你正在努力的方向。这确实能帮你屏蔽掉周围所有人和其他正在发生的事。它还能阻止我们变得被动，我想，仅仅把目光局限在脚下几步远的地方。就像它能阻止我们深陷于“一切都必须在当下完美无缺”的时刻。
Having a great life plan, I think helps us realize that, you know, we're not working for life to be great in five years, right? You're working for life to be great all up. So this aspiration actually makes decision making. I know it sounds kind of controversial or not controversial, but contradictory. It does make decision making easier because it takes away a lot of the urgency and the short-term anxiety of the perfect choice right now. And it just lets you see the long-term perspective for what you're working towards and the detours that the great life plan allows for. I think without a vision,
拥有一个伟大人生计划，我认为能帮助我们意识到，你知道的，我们工作不是为了让生活在五年后变得美好，对吧？你工作是为了让整个人生都变得美好。所以这种宏大的愿景实际上让做决定变得更容易了。我知道这听起来有点争议，或者说不是争议，而是矛盾。它确实让做决定变得更容易了，因为它消除了很多关于当下必须做出完美选择的紧迫感和短期焦虑。它只是让你看清你为之奋斗的长期前景，以及伟大人生计划所允许的各种迂回。我想如果没有一个愿景，
right, all good options look equally good and look equally promising and therefore the choice becomes equally stressful. When you have vision, the options become clearer because you can really identify what matches my vision, what doesn't, what energizes me, what doesn't. You're no longer just choosing randomly. You're no longer obsessing over the perfect choice because the vision stands regardless of the individual choices. You know, instead of asking, like, is this the perfect job? You're able to ask, does this move me further towards the life I want? Instead of like, what if I choose wrong. It's like, does this choice allow me to build skills or knowledge that are going to bring me value even if this doesn't work out? There is all this research and psychology on goal setting that
对吧，所有好的选择看起来都同样美好，也都同样大有前途，因此选择本身也就变得同样令人压力倍增。当你有了愿景，选择就会变得更加清晰，因为你能够真正辨别出什么符合我的愿景、什么不符合，什么能给我注入活力、什么不能。你不再只是随机选择。你不再对完美的抉择执念不放，因为无论具体的选择如何，愿景始终都在。你知道的，与其去问“这是完美的工作吗？”，你能够去问的是“这能让我离想要的生活更近一步吗？”而不是像“如果我选错了怎么办？”这种。而是变成“这个选择能否让我建立起即使事情没有成功也能带给我价值的技能或知识？”关于设定目标，有这么多的研究和心理学
shows having a meaningfully clear enough long-term goal, having some kind of aspiration will help you filter short-term options, even if that long-term aspiration changes. You stop asking, you know, what is perfect, you start asking, what thing is going to bring me closer, which, choice is more aligned with what I want to do versus the appearance or the expectations that others have from me. I also think the final importance of this is that it expands your possibility. Like this is not the decade to think small. If this episode has taught you anything in your 20s, it is very easy to unconsciously shrink your dreams to what feels realistic. And it's very easy to whittle everything down. And it becomes harder to re-expand that later
表明，拥有一个足够清晰有意义的长期目标，拥有某种抱负，将帮助你筛选短期的选择，即使那个长期的抱负发生了改变。你不再去问“什么是完美的”，你开始去问“什么事情能让我更接近目标”，哪个选择更符合我想做的事，而不是别人对我的外在看法或期望。我还认为这最后的重要性在于它拓展了你的可能性。这可不是格局变小的十年。如果这一集教会了你关于20多岁的什么道理，那就是非常容易在无意中把梦想缩小到感觉现实的范围内。而且你很容易把一切都削减掉。而且以后要想重新扩大
on because your brain feels even more foolish for doing so, because it's already closed off those possibilities. Having this deliberately, yeah, delusional vision pushes back against that natural cognitive narrowing that a lot of people experience the older they get. And instead it says, I'm going to choose to be optimistic. I'm going to choose to think big. I'm going to choose not to be realistic and see what happens. And that is strongly linked to long-term success. Genuinely, look at half the people that you admire, they would not, they are probably not the most talented. They are probably not the most hardworking. They probably are, but they're definitely not always the most talented. A great deal of their success comes down to delusion and the fact that they had the guts and the
就会变得更加困难，因为你的大脑会因为这样做而觉得自己更像个傻子，因为它已经把这些可能性给关闭了。故意持有这种“妄想般”的愿景，正是为了对抗许多人随着年龄增长而经历的那种自然的认知收缩。相反，它是在说：我选择保持乐观，我选择胸怀大志，我选择不那么现实，然后看看会发生什么。这与长期的成功有着密不可分的联系。说真的，看看你所崇拜的一半人，他们可能并不是最有天赋的。他们可能并不是最努力工作的。也许他们是，但他们绝对不总是最有天赋的。他们很大一部分的成功归结于这种“妄想”，以及他们有胆量和
courage and the belief to put themselves in Lux's kind of range, if that makes sense. Like, they allowed them to be a target for opportunities by increasing their presence and by increasing their commitment to what they wanted to do and just being like, I'm going to be in those spaces. This is not my time to think small. I'm going to risk everything. That is our next thing, the next thing on this list of like the things you should do in your 20s, bet everything on a risk because why not? Why not? Like genuinely, can you give me a reason why not? That you wouldn't eventually realize there's an excuse. Or can you give me a reason why not? Or can you give me a reason why not that wouldn't eventually be an amazing part of your origin story, wouldn't eventually be
勇气去相信，把自己置于“好运”的射程之内，如果这说得通的话。就像，他们通过提高自己的存在感、通过增加对自己想做之事的承诺，并抱着“我要进入那些领域”的心态，让自己成为了机会的目标。这不是我格局变小的时候。我要孤注一掷。这就是我们的下一件事，20多岁应该做的事情清单上的下一件：把一切都押在冒险上，因为为什么不呢？为什么不呢？说真的，你能给我一个“为什么不”的理由吗？最终你会发现那只是个借口。或者你能给我一个“为什么不”的理由吗？或者你能给我一个“为什么不”的理由，而这个理由最终不会成为你发家史中精彩绝伦的一部分，不会最终成为
the barrier that you overcome. Your 20s are, we say this all the time, uniquely designed for risk, for a lot of reasons. The first one being that the cost of failure is just naturally lower. You usually have fewer dependence, fewer financial obligations, fewer people relying on you. the margin for error may be wider, but if something collapses, you can rebuild. At 25, a failed business is just a story. At 45, it might involve savings, a mortgage, school fees. You have more flexibility around risk. You have more opportunities as well to just seem gutsy and for people to celebrate that and think that that is amazing. Think that you're really cool for doing that. The second reason I really think that you need to bet at all on risk is that
你所战胜的艰难险阻。我们总是这么说，20多岁是天生为冒险而设计的，原因有很多。第一个原因是失败的成本自然更低。你通常需要抚养的人更少，财务负担更少，依赖你的人更少。犯错的空间可能更宽裕，但如果有什么崩溃了，你还可以重建。在25岁时，一次失败的创业只是一个故事。而在45岁时，它可能牵涉到存款、房贷、学费。你在冒险方面拥有更多的灵活性。你也有更多机会表现得很有魄力，人们会为此庆祝并认为这太了不起了。会觉得你做这件事真的很酷。我真的认为你需要孤注一掷去冒险的第二个原因，是
we know regret will hit you harder than failure, right? Studies on long-term regret show that people regret inaction more than action over time. They are more likely to regret those moments of like, what if I tried over why didn't that work out? Your 20s are the time when you have more what ifs available to test and more regret to avoid. And more regret to a avoid by just trying. Third, I don't think you feel locked into one identity yet. Like, you don't have the weight of legacy weighing you down. If you start in your 30s, your 40s, your 50s, which of course you can, 70s, 80s, 90s, like, it's going to be a little bit harder because your identity is already solidified around probably one thing. There's reputation, there's history.
我们知道遗憾对你的打击会比失败更大，对吧？关于长期遗憾的研究表明，随着时间的推移，人们对不作为的遗憾多于对作为的遗憾。他们更有可能对那些“如果我试过就好了”的时刻感到遗憾，而不是对“为什么那没有成功”感到遗憾。20多岁正是你可以用来测试的“如果当初”更多、可以避免的遗憾更多的时期。而且可以通过去尝试来避免更多的遗憾。第三，我觉得你还没被锁定在某个单一的身份里。就像，你没有背负历史包袱的沉重感。如果你在30多岁、40多岁、50多岁时才开始，当然你完全可以，还有70岁、80岁、90岁，事情就会变得稍微困难一点，因为你的身份可能已经围绕着某一件事情固化了。有声誉，有历史。
Like, you are the lawyer, you are the accountant, you are the mother, like you have found your role. And so changing direction, the older you get and the longer you get, and the longer you, wait, can feel like you are dismantling more, but in your 20s, like, that structure just isn't there. The structure is a lot looser. You're allowed to contradict yourself. Like, people almost expect it. That you can be like pre-law one day, a photographer the next. You can move cities without it being called like a midlife crisis. You can reinvent your style, your politics, your ambitions, like your goals. And it's normalized. It's seen as exploration, not instability. And it's not that you can't continue to do that later in life.
比如，你是一名律师，你是一名会计，你是一位母亲，你已经找到了自己的角色。因此，随着年龄越来越大、时间越来越久，你改变方向时，就会觉得自己在拆除更多的东西，但在20多岁时，这种结构根本就不存在。这种结构要松散得多。你被允许自相矛盾。人们几乎对此习以为常。你可以今天准备学法律，明天就去当摄影师。你可以搬去别的城市，而不会被称为什么中年危机。你可以重塑你的风格、你的政治立场、你的野心，比如你的目标。这是被正常化的。这被视为一种探索，而不是不稳定。并不是说你在人生晚期就不能继续这样做了。
I know so many people who are, like, I have somebody I know who's like in their 50s who was going back to like med school. You have so many opportunities to be able to do that. It's just that now your emotional tolerance and the flexibility of your life to handle this and to handle things going wrong is just more adaptable. And it's just, yeah, more flexible. There's just a little bit more give and take, I guess, to the risks you're taking and to the fact that they might not work out. So if you have a risk in mind that you're like, I don't know if I can go that big.
我认识好多这样的人，比如我认识一个50多岁的人，正打算回医学院读书。你有大把的机会能够做到这一点。只是现在你的情绪承受能力以及生活应对这种变化和事情出错时的灵活性要适应性更强一些。而且它就是，对吧，更有弹性。对于你冒的险以及它们可能不会成功这件事，我觉得生活包容度和缓冲余地要稍微大一点。所以，如果你心里有一个冒险的想法，而你在想：“我不知道自己能不能搞这么大。”
I don't know if that's really for me. I'm too scared that it might not work out. Like, you have very little to lose that is tangible. Maybe some, maybe money, maybe what reputation, maybe you do fail. I just think the story of failure is just a much more enjoyable and entertaining one than the story of not trying. Because at least in the story of failure, somebody did something. At least you did something. At least you tried.
“我不知道这真的适合我吗。我太害怕它可能不会成功了。”你看，你几乎没有什么实质性的东西会失去。也许会失去一些钱，也许会失去声誉，也许你真的失败了。我只是觉得，失败的故事比不去尝试的故事要有趣得多、也具有观赏性得多。因为至少在失败的故事里，有人做过点什么。至少你做过点什么。至少你尝试过了。
So I think you owe it to yourself. Okay, we're going to take one more short break before we get into our final five. Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator of the available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical
所以我觉得你欠自己一个交代。好了，在我们进入最后五点之前，我们要休息一会儿。不要走开。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际
and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What's that? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count?
且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经真的相信种子油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会迎来一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方的“TWO percent”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍了两下小金姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。是什么？乔治·布什跟小金姆有什么关系？
Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。其中包括最近一期与马卡蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅因为可卡因。我随时可以聊聊当年的可卡因，只是让大家知道我的意思。我是说，马卡蒙特，这已经是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我带来了十多年来
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person
我在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们去追求某样东西时，
while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
我们深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们都在盯着积分榜。生活变成了输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯。因为你觉得在这里活着就要做一个好人，
learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search, learn the hard way, and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court. Court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
你是出于恐惧才做一个好人吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客中展开关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话：
I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
《Learn the Hard Way》。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”，现在就收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by.
听证会暴露了她言辞中惊人的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的寻找真相的法庭之战。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州，正义得到伸张之前，这还不算结束。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。
I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
规则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。不作死就不会死。规则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在这个新季的《女友们》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, number 11, do a social audit. What I mean by this is look around at your close friends, look around at your relationships and really analyze, is this person a reflection of who I want to be? Is this person good for me? And am I good for them? Do I like being around these kinds of people? Do I like who I am with these kinds of people? You've probably heard of the rule of five, which is that we are the five people we are closest to. And so you have to choose carefully. Like that's something that was very drilled into me when I was younger. Psychology says that's not entirely accurate. It's more like 15 with a few core
我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己动手。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。
relationships, like impacting us the most, like a partner or a best friend. But it does, this rule of five does strike at a core human fact. Like you become who you surround yourself with. So if your friends, I know it's going to sound harsh, but if your friends do not inspire you, if your friends do not make you want to be better, if your friends do not make a big deal about you, do not make you feel great about yourself, do not push you to be better. Like you are missing out on one of the easiest ways to make your life better, which is to have great friends. And maybe that hesitation and that doubt around your friendships is pushing you to find some better people. There was this amazing study that was published in 2024 titled, I think emotion contagion and like psychological
在Iheart radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。好了，第十一点，做一次社交审计。我的意思是，环顾一下你的密友，审视一下你的人际关系，并真正分析一下：这个人是我想要成为的人的写照吗？这个人对我好吗？我对他们好吗？我喜欢和这样的人在一起吗？我喜欢和这样的人在一起时的自己吗？你可能听说过五人定律，即我们就是我们最亲密的五个人。所以你必须谨慎选择。这是我年轻时被反复灌输的观念。心理学表明这并不完全准确。更像是15个人，其中有几个核心的
synchrony or something. And in this study, it looked at a number of friendship dyads, so pairs of friends, and what it found was that their emotional states were literally contagious to their other friend compared to strangers. So like in this room, they would have one of the friends, one member of the friendship, like watching a movie, a very sad movie, a very happy movie, a very scary movie, and they would have the other friend watching them, and they had them tied up to all this like cool, fancy equipment. And what they would find was that even though there were no words being spoken, even though the friend was not watching the movie, just watching their own friend's reaction, impacted their emotional state,
人际关系对我们的影响最大，比如伴侣或最好的朋友。但五人定律确实切中了人类的一个核心事实。就像你周围都是什么人，你就会成为什么样的人。所以如果你的朋友——我知道这听起来很刺耳——如果你的朋友不能激励你，如果你的朋友不能让你想要变得更好，如果你的朋友不把你当回事，不能让你对自我感觉良好，不能推动你变得更好，那么你就错失了让生活变好的最简单的方法之一，那就是拥有好朋友。也许那种对友谊的犹豫和怀疑正在促使你去寻找更好的人。2024年发表过一项令人惊叹的研究，题目似乎是关于情绪传染和心理
impacted how they were responding in a completely separate environment. The emotions, the mood, the personalities, the attitude, the mindset of your friends is contagious. It's called social osmosis. Well, that's kind of what I like to call it. Social osmosis, which is that like being around somebody will imbue parts of you with parts of their character. That is like a deep responsibility of our friends. A deep responsibility of our friends and in us choosing our friends is to choose people whose influence on us is going to be for good and whose character, life we can look at and say, I genuinely admire you and I admire what you're doing so much so that like I want a piece of that. Like I want that to influence me. You know, do a friendship.
同步之类的。在这项研究中，它观察了许多友谊双人组，也就是成对的朋友，它发现与陌生人相比，他们的情绪状态对彼此的朋友具有字面意义上的传染性。就像在这个房间里，他们会安排其中一个朋友，即友谊中的一员，去观看一部电影，一部非常悲伤的电影、一部非常快乐的电影、一部非常吓人的电影，然后让另一个朋友观察他们，并且他们身上连着各种很酷的高端设备。结果他们发现，即便没有说任何话，即便那个朋友没有看电影，仅仅是看着自己朋友的反应，都会影响到他们自己的情绪状态，
order at some point in your 20s, look around at your friends and just not in a callous way, not in a cruel way, but just really ask yourself, like, are we what's best for each other? And people have bad weeks, people have bad months. People have bad years. Like, I've definitely had a few bad years. So I'm not saying cut out all your friends who are like downers. But do really consider whether either of you, both of you are getting what you deserve out of friendship.
影响他们在完全不同的环境中的反应。你朋友的情绪、心情、性格、态度和心态是具有传染性的。这叫做社会渗透。好吧，这就是我喜欢称呼它的名字。社会渗透，也就是说，和某人在一起会让你身上的某些部分浸染上他们性格中的一部分。这是我们对朋友肩负的深重责任。我们在选择朋友时肩负的深重责任，就是选择那些对我们的影响是积极的、且其性格和生活我们可以看着并说“我由衷地钦佩你，我非常钦佩你的所作所为，以至于我也想要那样的一部分，我希望那能对产生影响”的人。你知道的，在20多岁的某个时候，做一次友谊
And don't be afraid at some stage to be like, hey, no, like, I want. want more for myself and I want more out of the people who I choose to spend my time around. Like, I want, I want to prioritize people who prioritize me. Number 12, do something physically and mentally challenging in your 20s just to prove you can. I know we talked about like the quitting something you're dependent on. This is like a physical challenge. Whether it is a like multi-day hike, whether it is a marathon, whatever it is. Whether it is, whether it is, whether it is, a pilgrimage, a lot of these are really like hiking related. At some stage in your 20s, choose like a physical thing and you know you're going to have to push yourself hard to
盘点，环顾一下你的朋友，不是以一种冷酷的方式，不是以一种残酷的方式，而是真正地问问自己：我们真的是彼此最好的选择吗？人们都会有状态不好的星期，人们会有状态不好的月份。人们会有状态不好的年份。比如，我确实也经历过几个状态不好的年份。所以我不是说要切断所有那些情绪低落的朋友。但确实要好好考虑一下，你们两个或你们彼此是否都从这段友谊中得到了应得的东西。
complete and really say to yourself, I'm going to do that. I'm going to complete this. This is going to be my mission for the next however many months, however many years. I know I made this video the other day that was like, I know I can do hard things. Now I, now I, now I, I need to learn easy things. So this might sound like kind of hypocritical. But I do think that you can only grow as far as you can see yourself suffering, which sounds really awful. But what I mean by that is like there's, if you really believe like I can't do that and it's all in your head, or if there are things that you genuinely are like, I don't have what it takes to try this thing. I don't have what it takes to do this risk. I don't have what it takes to like put myself out there.
而且在某个阶段不要害怕去说：不，我为自己想要更多，我对我选择花时间相处的人也有更多要求。我想优先考虑那些优先考虑我的人。第十二点，在20多岁时做一件在身体和精神上都极具挑战性的事情，只为了证明你能做到。我知道我们讨论过放弃你所依赖的东西。这是一个身体上的挑战。无论它是多日徒步旅行，还是马拉松，无论它是什么。无论它是，无论它是，无论它是朝圣，其中很多都确实与徒步有关。在20多岁的某个阶段，选择一件你知道自己必须拼尽全力才能
doing a task, doing a challenge like this that puts you in probably a very similar mental state of suffering, of pain, of just like frustration, and then showing yourself step by step, moment by moment that you are capable of taking that bad day, taking that bad mood, taking that leg cramp, whatever it is, and moving through it is so psychologically powerful for anything else you want to do in life. It's so psychologically powerful because it, much like the quitting the thing you're dependent on, much like, I guess, the addiction part of this conversation, it just rewires your brain and it rewires yourself for self-belief and for self-trust and for knowing that you are capable of so much more. So add that to your bucket list, a physically challenging
完成的体力挑战，并真正对自己说：我要完成它。我要完成这个。这将是我接下来几个月、甚至几年里的任务。我知道我前几天发了个视频说：我知道我能做困难的事。现在我需要学习简单的事。所以这听起来可能有点虚伪。但我确实认为，你的成长极限只取决于你能忍受痛苦的极限，这听起来真的很糟糕。但我的意思是，如果你真的相信“我做不到”，而这全都是你的心理作用，或者如果你有些事情真心觉得“我没有能力去尝试这件事。我没有能力去冒这个险。我没有能力去表现自己”。
adventure that you're going to tick off by the time you turn 30. This one is also, I think, extra special and extra important and also quite intangible, so I'm sorry, but learn how to stop hating yourself. At some stage, you've got to learn, like, hating yourself doesn't help with anything. You might think that it helps with discipline. You might think that it helps you, I don't know, work harder, do whatever. Like, I remember thinking that, like, if I hated myself enough, like, I would finally have, like, the motivation to do things, and I'd finally, like, be able to beat myself into submission when it came to my dreams. It never worked. Like, self-hatred is, yeah, an incredibly powerful motivator, but it also is terrible for performance.
去做这样一件任务、这样一个挑战，它可能会把你置于一种非常类似的充满痛苦、折磨以及纯粹挫败感的精神状态中，然后一步步、一刻刻地向自己证明，你有能力挺过那个糟糕的日子、调整那个糟糕的心情、克服那腿部的痉挛，无论那是什么，并坚持走过去——这对于你想在生活中做的任何其他事情来说，在心理上都具有强大的力量。它在心理上太有力量了，因为它就像戒掉你依赖的东西一样，就像这场对话中关于上瘾的部分一样，它会重塑你的大脑，重塑你的自信和对自己的信任，让你知道自己有能力做到更多。所以把这个加入你的愿望清单吧：一项身体上极具挑战性的
So if you do one thing in your 20s, if you finish your 20s and you have done, you've never gotten a job, you've never been in a relationship. you've never moved out of home, whatever. You have not a dime to your name, but you can genuinely say, like, but I really, I really love myself and I learn how to stop hating myself. I still think that's a win. If you've done like nothing else on this list, like you are further ahead in life than 99% of people.
冒险，在30岁之前把它打卡完成。我认为这个也特别特别重要，而且也相当抽象，所以请见谅：学会停止自我厌恶。在某个阶段，你必须明白，自我厌恶对解决任何问题都没有帮助。你可能会觉得它有助于自律。你可能会觉得它能帮你，我不知道，工作更努力，或者做点别的。我记得我曾经以为，如果我足够厌恶自己，我终于就会有动力去做事情，而且在面对梦想时，我终于能把自我鞭笞得服服帖帖。这从来都没用。自我厌恶虽然是一种极其强大的动力，但它对表现来说同样糟糕。
What are we up to? I think number 14, spend a week alone, whether that is like in the neighboring town, solo traveling, in your own city, not seeing your friends, walking on around doing your own thing, spend a week alone by yourself. You have no idea how much of our lives are wired around others for good and for bad, right? We're social animals, but their needs, their preferences, their opinions, their direction, whether it's your boss, your partner, your friends, strangers, like people that you know, most of us structure our nervous systems around other people. We regulate through venting and conversation or through distraction or
所以，如果你在20多岁时只做了一件事，如果你度过了20多岁的尾声，却从来没有找到过工作，从来没有谈过恋爱，从来没有搬出过家，不管怎样。你名下一无所有，但你能够由衷地宣称：“但我真的、真的很爱我自己，我学会了停止自我厌恶。”我依然认为这是一场胜利。如果你完成了清单上的其他所有空白，那你也比99%的人在人生道路上走得更远。
validation. We get our sense of identity from what other people think of us. We let our lives be directed by their desires. When you leave that, even temporarily, your brain is going to recalibrate to a crazy extent. And it's painful at first. There was a 2014 study, very famous that found that, like, amongst these participants, the majority of people would rather mildly electrocute themselves with an electric shock than spend 15 minutes with their thoughts. That is how uncomfortable solitude is for us. But choosing to voluntarily step into solitude will literally change your internal wiring so fast if you choose to do so. It will give you such a power search, such an identity boost on such a sped-up timeline.
我们进行到哪儿了？我想第十四点，独自度过一周，无论那是在邻近的城镇、独自旅行、在你自己所在的城市里，不见你的朋友，四处走走做你自己的事，独自度过一个星期。你根本不知道我们的生活在多大程度上是为了迎合他人而构建的，有好也有坏，对吧？我们是社会动物，但他们的需求、他们的偏好、他们的意见、他们的方向，无论是你的老板、你的伴侣、你的朋友、陌生人，还是你认识的人，我们大多数人的神经系统都是围绕着其他人来构建的。我们通过宣泄和对话，或者通过分散注意力或
In the first like 24 to 48 hours, you're going to feel really uncomfortable. There's going to be this deep urge to reach out to somebody to go get dinner, to go on social media, to like fill the silence. then your brain starts to basically realize that that's not an option and something starts to change. Something interesting happens. Research by neuroscientists essentially show that your brain starts to be like, oh, I'm actually very, very interesting. It starts to really like uncover new facets of what you're doing. It's called constructive internal reflection, essentially like your brain's default, like,
寻求认可来进行自我调节。我们的身份感来自别人对我们的看法。我们让自己的生活被他们的欲望所左右。当你离开这一切，哪怕只是暂时的，你的大脑也会在疯狂的程度上进行重新校准。而且一开始它是痛苦的。2014年有一项非常著名的研究发现，在这些参与者中，大多数人宁愿用电击对自己进行轻度电击，也不愿花15分钟和自己的思想独处。这就是独处对我们来说是多么令人不适。但选择主动走进独处，如果你选择这样做，将以惊人的速度改变你的内在神经回路。它会以一种加速的时间线给你带来如此强大的能量冲击和身份提升。
mode network is activated. This is like responsible for self-referential thinking, for like autobiographical memory. Suddenly these different new but old parts of you, like you become really awakened to it. People report leaving periods of solitude or leaving voluntary time like spent by themselves with a whole new sense of themselves that feels almost like ancient and authentic to them. Like in such a emotionally, socially, like, stimulated world and environment where your phone can like essentially give you any emotion that you want to feel when it's so much easier to like talk to people or let other people regulate our emotions for us. Stepping away from that and just allowing ourselves to just be incredibly flexible and in our own
在最初的24到48小时里，你会感到非常不舒服。你会产生一种强烈的冲动，想要联系某人去吃晚饭、刷社交媒体，来填补这份寂静。然后你的大脑基本上开始意识到这不是一个选项，有些事情开始发生改变。有趣的事情发生了。神经科学家的研究基本上表明，你的大脑开始觉得：“噢，其实我非常非常有趣。”它开始真正发掘你正在做的事情的新层面。这被称为建设性的内省，本质上就是你大脑的默认模式网络被激活了。这负责与自我相关的思考，负责自传式的记忆。突然之间，你身上这些不同但古老的部分——你对它们变得真正觉醒。人们报告说，在经历了一段独处时间或主动独处之后离开时，会带着一种全新的自我感，这种感觉对他们来说几乎是古老而真实的。在一个情感上、社会层面上受到如此多刺激的世界和环境中，你的手机基本上可以提供你想感受的任何情绪，当与人交流或让其他人帮我们调节情绪变得如此容易时。从这种状态中抽离出来，哪怕只有一个星期，也仅仅是让自己在自己的
world and on our own timeline, even just for a week is such a spiritual experience, to be honest. Especially if you combine it with travel, we've got a whole episode on like the psychology of solo travel with all of the statistics and the findings and the studies on the power of this, but I think it's one of the best things that you can do. My final thing on this list, the final thing I think you need to do in your 20s, change your mind about something, change your mind about a belief, about a person. about an opinion. This is something that I've done in the past year that humbled me deeply and then
世界里、按照自己的时间线无比灵活地存在，老实说，这是一种极其神圣的体验。特别是如果你把它和旅行结合起来的话，我们有一整集关于独自旅行心理学的节目，里面有关于这种力量的所有统计数据、发现和研究，但我认为这是你能做的最好的事情之一。清单上的最后一件事，我认为你在20多岁时需要做的最后一件事：改变你对某件事的看法，改变你对某个信仰、某个人、某个观点的看法。这是我在过去一年里做过的一件事，它深深地让我感到谦卑，并且
genuinely changed my life because a lot of our, I think our youth, I don't know, our youth, our younger years is, like a whole part of growing up is that you is putting yourself at the center, right? When you're a kid, you're at the center of all your own stories. you're at the center of all your own experiences. Same as when you're a teenager. When you're in your 20s as well, like there is a real, I don't know,
真正地改变了我的生活。因为我们的许多——我认为我们的青春，我不知道，我们的青春，我们年轻的岁月是——成长的一个整体部分就是把自己放在中心，对吧？当你还是个孩子的时候，你是自己所有故事的中心。你是自己所有经历的中心。当你还是个青少年时也是如此。当你处于20多岁时，同样有某种真实的，我不知道，
like developmental incentive to be quite selfish and self-centered and to really think that you know everything and to be right because it's protecting your ego, right? And it's protecting your identity and it's trying to make you feel good about yourself. I think one of the biggest signs of maturity and one of the biggest signs that like you have really learned some solid lessons from your 20s
像是一种发展的动力，会变得相当自私和自我中心，并且真的认为自己无所不知、永远正确，因为这在保护你的自我，对吧？它在保护你的身份认同，并试图让你对自己感觉良好。我认为成熟的最大标志之一，也是你真正从20多岁学到扎实教训的最大标志之一，
is when you are able to say, this is something I once believed and I do not believe it anymore. And I'm okay with the friction that causes within myself. I am okay with acknowledging that I was wrong and that I am not a perfect person and that somebody else might know more than me and that somebody else's opinion might be more correct than mine. I just think that that is so great for cognitive flexibility, so great for our relationships, the people who grow up to find love very hard. friendship very hard, marriage very hard, work very hard. I think what I've often heard and seen is it's the people who are never able to have any empathy for how others operate because they are
就是当你能够说：“这是我曾经相信的东西，而我不再相信它了。”并且我能够接受它在我内心引起的摩擦。我能够接受承认自己是错的，承认我不是一个完美的人，承认别人可能比我知道得更多，别人的观点可能比我更正确。我只是觉得这对于认知灵活性太棒了，对我们的人际关系也太棒了。那些在成长过程中发现去爱非常难、发现友谊非常难、婚姻非常难、工作非常难的人。我想我经常听到和看到的是，这些人从来无法对别人的运作方式产生任何同理心，因为他们
never able to see themselves as being wrong. Their ego remains so rigid. So I think that's something that all of us could really benefit from working on. That is all for our 400th episode. Thank you so much if you have listened this far. I think if you've done even half of these things on this list. Maybe you are like sitting there being like, I've done them all. I have done these all. I'm good to go. Well then congratulations. Send it to a friend who you think may be struggling with some milestone anxiety if you think this less traditional list might be helpful for them. Might be helpful for like the comparison trap. Might be helpful for a bit of anxiety they're having about their 20s and have they done enough and will they do enough. I hope it
从来无法看到自己也有出错的时候。他们的自我依然那么僵化。所以我想这是我们所有人都真正能从中受益并加以改进的事情。这就是我们第400集的全部内容。非常感谢你收听了这么久。我想如果你甚至完成了这份清单上的一半事情。也许你正坐在那里想着：“我都做完了。这些我都做过了。我已经准备好了。”那我要祝贺你。把这发给一个你认为可能正在苦于应对某种里程碑焦虑的朋友，如果你认为这份不太传统的清单对他们会有所帮助的话。可能有助于摆脱比较陷阱。可能有助于缓解他们对20多岁的某些焦虑，比如自己做得够不够、未来还能不能做好。我希望这也能
helps them as well. Remember that if you are in Australia, the UK, New Zealand, all the US, Canada, can't even say all the places. Just if you think, if you want to watch it, go see if it's on Netflix. It just might be there in your country. Again, I want to thank you if you have been here since yesterday, if you have been here since 2021, five years ago now. Thank you for listening to the podcast. Thank you for supporting it. Every single thing is because of you guys and because of the support that you have shown just by listening. So I'm very deeply grateful on this day and all of the others. But as we wrap up this episode, remember, be safe, be kind, be gentle with yourself.
对他们有所帮助。记住，如果你在澳大利亚、英国、新西兰，或者美国、加拿大，我甚至说不全所有地方。总之如果你想看的话，去看看它是否在Netflix上。它可能就在你所在国家的平台上。再次感谢大家，如果你从昨天开始就在这里，或者如果你从2021年（也就是五年前）开始就在这里。感谢你收听这个播客。感谢你的支持。每一件事都归功于你们大家，归功于你们仅仅通过收听所给予的支持。所以在今天以及其他所有日子里，我都深表感激。在我们结束这一集之际，请记住：注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。
And thank you as always for tuning in. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships
感谢大家一如既往地收听。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇异的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast.
你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收看《回首播客》。
For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
对1979年来说，那对我是一个重大的时刻。对我和说84年很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite. therapist and hosts care games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not
我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听《Look Back At It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜爱的心理治疗师兼主持人 Care Games 主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不
mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor Star, Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
意味着你就必须这么做。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克哈德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。
When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
当一群女性发现她们都和同一个高产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你听播客的地方收听。
This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。